christmas may be in our rear-view mirror
but now we're moving into a post-holiday
tradition returning all those gifts we
don't want with online sales expected to
hit a record 207 billion dollars in the
u.s there could also be a record number
of returns this year every year a big
chunk of those returns end up in
landfills enough to fill
23 million refrigerators or 6400 747s
can you imagine that
yeah janet chamberlain has an inside
look at e-tailers that are trying to
make returns more sustainable
[Music]
it's a familiar scene this time of year
thanks bud appreciate it delivery
workers making the trek to your front
door with those point-and-click gifts
online purchases have never been a
bigger part of the holiday likely to top
25 of sales but here's the more
startling number the e-commerce return
rate is 25
one of every four items purchased online
is sent back compared to about eight
percent for a physical store and this is
what that can look like mountains of
cardboard and plastic packaging with
valuable merchandise inside
so retailers really aren't equipped to
take the product back the typical
retailer
hasn't invested in this yet and you'll
see all their returns come back they
pile up they sit and it often
quarterly or twice a year they might
liquidate them for pennies on the dollar
or even potentially destroy them tobin
moore is the ceo of optoro which helps
companies solve the problem of a tsunami
of returns we have now these new racks
behind me here where we put bulk cases
this massive warehouse outside nashville
is one of three dozen optoro uses across
the country processing merchandise for
sellers like american eagle target bed
bath and beyond and others
workers use optoro software to check in
the merchandise ensuring a refund then
relisting the product for a new sale
we're just here to just grade it and
make sure that it has a upc and it has
the correct description
these items will never go back to the
retailer's warehouse they're held here
until sold again
the volume here is incredible on just
these two racks there are more than 120
000 items that came in as returns and
most will leave this warehouse as a new
sale within a week their house here it's
the most efficient thing wherever that
good comes back if you can get it back
to stock from there it means less
shipments less touches less waste
and it has to be eighty-nine percent of
online customers say they won't buy
again if the return process is difficult
in houston abby mcdonald used happy
returns
a service that collects customers
unwanted goods for hundreds of companies
that sold them it's postage and box free
did you already start online i did i
have the code perfect a qr code is all
you need mcdonald's sent back a dress
she bought online from the women's
clothing company draper james and it's
close to my office which made it easy to
pop out at lunch and
drop it off here for free paper source
locations like this are among 3 800
collection points nationwide an average
of 20 returns from multiple sellers
shipped in a single box reducing waste
and expediting turnaround time and it
increases foot traffic for the store
collecting the goods
the clothing store everlane takes more
than 70 percent of its unwanted items
back through happy returns
everlane's katina bodis says making
returns seamless is critical not just
for customers but for the company's
bottom line i think the speed and the
efficiency with which we can get the
product back
on the shelf and available for another
customer is really integral to our
overall business model it obviously
impacts our sales and our revenue and
the environment almost 6 billion tons of
returned items will end up in landfills
after the holiday season
an item is the wrong fit for a consumer
finding the right one for that returned
product is key our technology connects
every returned item no matter the
condition to its next best home as
efficiently as possible minimizing
shipments and getting that product back
into stock quickly a win for buyer
seller and the planet
for cbs mornings i'm janet chamleon in
lebanon tennessee
it's a win-win-win yeah i have to be
honest this is part of the shopping
experience that i don't keep in
consideration when i'm shopping because
i oftentimes think about the gift that i
want or i'm sending somebody else but i
don't think about what happens when that
gift doesn't work out exactly well who
would return your gifts nate well yeah
that's what i'm saying
but you know what there's also always a
salvation army just that's true thrift
store all those places will gladly take
those gifts too and i love to read gift
yeah
that's that's a good idea and also
listen we can all practice being
minimalist and and try to buy things
that are more sustainable that last
longer and things that you know most
people don't have to return because when
you buy in bulk you know you're
oftentimes going to return something
yeah and it's hard with clothes though
especially us women so we like to switch
it up yes and with the way you guys
dress i know you got closets full of
clothes
all right